with this in mind your next assignment
requires you to use the data file you've
parsed to render the few images on the
screen you're going to need to fill out
the two functions below to properly draw
images on the screen now before you get
started let's talk about something real
quick note that before now your artists
are actually generating assets
referencing loose files an artist
creates some sort of texture they put it
on disk and then they reference an
object to that texture well of course is
a post process we've all crammed that
into a small little box and we now have
a missing correlation the artists file
is still going to reference the loose
asset but we've got it sitting around in
a larger texture how do we make a
connection between the two the draw
sprite function needs to fix this it
assumes that it's going to be given a
sprite name which represents the name of
the loose asset file as well as the
position X in position Y on where it
wants to render it on the canvas since
we're just given a sprite name we need
to map where that sprite name exists
inside of the atlases that we've loaded
now for your benefit we're going to help
you out with this taking a look at the
top of the file we define a global
dictionary object that represents every
sprite sheet that's been loaded in the
load function for sprite sheet we go
ahead and add this sprite sheet into the
global array setting the sheet name as
the key for the dictionary element what
this will allow you to do is when you're
given the sprite name inside of the draw
function you can iterate through all of
the sprite sheets and for each sprite
sheet determine whether or not the given
sprite name exists in the sprites that
have been defined for that sheet this
should be pretty straightforward since
we've already covered the defined sprite
function and you already have a list
that includes a name once the draw
sprite function figures out what atlas
this given sprite is actually in it can
pass that data to draw sprite internal
handing off the sprite information what
atlas sheet it's coming from as well as
the position x and y that was given to
us from draw sprite draw sprite internal
should actually do the heavy lifting of
positioning the element and drawing it
to the world
taking advantage of the draw image API
that we just covered with all of its new
fancy bells and whistle parameters